Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest is History, where today we are going off with a bang because we are talking about Pompeii, Herculaneum, Vesuvius, the works. I'm Tom Holland and with me is my co-conspirator Dominic Sandbrook. And Dominic, thank thank you very very much for allowing me to do Pompeii. It's really kind of you. You don't dare to face me on your own do you Tom? That's true and I'm very very happy to announce that we have a very special guest with us today.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，今天我们将以极其震撼的方式开场，因为我们要聊的是庞贝、赫库兰尼姆、维苏威火山，所有这些。我是汤姆·霍兰，与我同行的是我的同谋多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，非常非常感谢你允许我来主讲庞贝。你真是太好了。你不敢自己一个人跟我过招，对吧，汤姆？
Sophie Hay who is an archaeologist who's worked at Pompeii and the adjoining areas for 25 years, runs the Pompeii social media accounts, is just about to start a book on women archaeologists who worked at Pompeii, so there couldn't be anyone better to talk about the site. Sophie, welcome to the podcast. Thank you. Hello. Well, thanks for having me. It's a pleasure, Sophie. So obviously, I'm terribly excited to be doing one on pompeii me too tom me too i think it would only be fair to hand over to dominic to ask the first question because otherwise i'm just going to kind of explode with excitement okay thank you tom sophie i went to pompeii on honeymoon in 2007 um along with you know a billion other people and it's a it's a kind of weird place
确实如此，而且我非常非常高兴地宣布，今天我们请到了一位特别的嘉宾。苏菲·海，她是一位在庞贝及周边地区工作了25年的考古学家，负责庞贝的社交媒体账号，并且刚刚开始着手写一本关于在庞贝工作的女性考古学家的书，所以没有人比她更适合来聊聊这个遗址了。苏菲，欢迎来到播客。谢谢。大家好。嗯，谢谢邀请我。这是我的荣幸，苏菲。所以显而易见，我超级兴奋能做一期关于庞贝的节目。我也是，汤姆，我也是。我觉得把第一个问题交给多米尼克问才算公平，否则我整个人就要因为兴奋而爆炸了。好吧，谢谢你，汤姆。苏菲，我2007年度蜜月的时候去过庞贝，嗯，还有其他大约十亿人，它是一个有点奇怪的地方，对吧？
isn't it because it's both an archaeological site where you sort of dig for historical artifacts and for insights into history but it's also basically the roman disney world right i mean there's a kind of tension there isn't there it's a sort of strange must be a weird thing for you for whom it's work and most people just go on a day trip and they're interested in the gift shop and then you know sunshades and coke and all this sort of stuff so does that seem kind of weird to you to be working amidst all that um it's it's interesting i mean when i was working there i was mainly in a part where the tourists couldn't be so i was kind of you know shielded from all of that but I did work in the forum uh at one point and that it was like being a sort of museum exhibit yourself um tourists
因为它既是一个考古遗址——你在那里发掘历史文物并寻找对历史的见解，但它基本上也是罗马的迪士尼世界，对吧？我的意思是，这其中存在一种张力，不是吗？这是一种奇怪的体验，对你来说，这是你的工作，而大多数人只是去那儿进行一日游，他们对纪念品商店感兴趣，然后是遮阳伞、可乐以及所有这类东西。所以在所有这些喧嚣中工作，对你来说是不是感觉有点怪？嗯，这挺有意思的。我的意思是，当我工作的时候，我主要在一个游客进不去的地方，所以我多少（从所有这些喧嚣中）得到了一些保护。不过我确实在广场工作过，嗯，有一段时间，那感觉就像自己成了博物馆里的展品一样，游客们
coming up saying have you found any dinosaurs yet and I must be in about six billion people's photograph albums because everyone's taking photographs so yeah that kind of when it was really in my face it was it was weird and also work was very slow because you were just answering questions um but it's also great because you know that what you're doing matters and means something to so many people so there's a kind of that side of it i i adore i just love people's fascination continual sort of questions about sight um and what we're doing. So, yeah. It does make you uneasy that it's become a kind of, a sort of, well, you know,
走过来问：“你们发现恐龙了吗？”而且我大概出现在大约六十亿人的相册里，因为每个人都在拍照。所以，是的，当这种干扰真切地摆在眼前时，感觉确实很怪。而且工作进展也很慢，因为你一直在回答问题。但这也很好，因为你知道你做的事情很重要，对这么多人来说有着特殊的意义。所以其中也有好的一面，我非常喜欢，我就是喜欢人们对这个遗址持续的 fascinat（着迷）以及他们各种各样的问题，还有我们在做的事情。所以，是的。这确实让人感到有些不安，它变成了一种，某种——好吧，你知道的，
how many coach loads of American, Chinese and British tourists go to Pompeii every year and sort of troop round and then troop off again. Yeah, no, that bit always makes me sad because I just think they do. They go to three main things. They see the forum, they see the brothelel they laugh in the brothel then they go and see one house and then they're back on their coach and they go off to you know have a nice lunch somewhere yeah um it does because i just feel like they haven't had the most of it but you know at the same time there are people who stay there for days on end and you know really try and embrace
每年有多少满载美国、中国和英国游客的大巴前往庞贝，像军队一样巡游一番，然后又像军队一样离开。是的，不，那部分总是让我感到难过，因为我只是觉得他们确实如此。他们只看三个主要地方。他们看广场，他们看妓院——他们在妓院里笑，然后他们去看一座房子，接着就回到大巴上，去某个地方吃顿美餐。是的，嗯，确实如此，因为我只是觉得他们没有领略到庞贝的精华。但你知道，与此同时，也有那些在那里待上好几天的人，他们（你知道的）真正试着去拥抱
everything so so for you you you hinted um at the fact that obviously lots of it is open to the public but also quite a lot isn't and even more hasn't even been excavated yeah and one of the excitements that's going on at the moment is that there's a kind of a surge of fresh fresh excavations so can you just give us a sense of um how much remains to be opened and what the most exciting recent discoveries have been well what remains to be opened is really hard to say because it changes every five minutes as they're doing conservation they open up a new house but then they close another one so that it kind of gets a break from tourists trooping in and out with
这一切。所以，对于你而言，你刚刚暗示了，很显然，许多地方对公众开放，但也有相当一部分没有开放，甚至有更多地方根本还没被发掘。是的，目前最令人兴奋的事情之一就是有一股全新的发掘浪潮。所以你能给我们讲讲，还有多少地方有待发掘，以及最近最令人兴奋的发现是什么吗？嗯，说实话，还有多少地方没开发真的很难说，因为这每五分钟都在变。当他们在进行文物保护时，他们会开放一座新房子，但随后又会关闭另一座，好让它从游客背着背包进进出出、在壁画上蹭来蹭去的情况中休息一下。所以这个遗址总是处于某种不断变化的状态。它，你知道的，有些地方只在早上开放。有些建筑只在下午开放。所以他们正试图错开开放时间，以此来提供一些帮助。但就完全没有被发掘的部分而言，大约占整个城镇的三分之一。所以仍然有很大一部分没有被发掘。除此之外，还有一些种植西红柿的农场，
their backpacks scratching along the frescoes and things. So it's kind of always in kind of flux, the site. It's, you know, and some are only open in the morning. Some buildings are only open in the afternoon. So they're trying to kind of stagger it a bit just to kind of help. But in terms of what hasn't been excavated at all, it's about one third of the town. So it's still a huge amount that hasn't been excavated. And on top of that, there's sort of farms growing tomatoes,
我以前经常去那里偷西红柿做三明治，这就是为什么我知道它们在那儿。是的，因为众所周知，这里的土壤之所以如此肥沃，是因为它是火山灰质的。从某种意义上说，这是一种与魔鬼的交易，不是吗？所以我想我们应该在大致勾勒出你能看到什么以及现状如何之后，简单谈谈庞贝和赫库兰尼姆是如何被保存下来的，
which I used to go and steal for sandwiches, which is why I know they're up there. Yeah, because famously, the reason why the soil is so fertile is because it's volcanic. So in a sense, it's kind of devil's bargain, isn't there? So I guess we should, having just kind of vaguely sketched out what you can see and what the state of play is now we should talk briefly about how it is that Pompeii and Herculaneum have been preserved
嗯，因为这可能是历史上最著名的火山爆发，对吧？呃，是的，我同意这一点。呃，是的。所以整个喷发过程总共持续了大约24小时，我认为；所以它有点像是一场缓慢燃烧的爆发，这就是为什么我们发现，我觉得，依然有那么多人留在那里，因为人们不断地想：“我们会没事的，我们会没事的。”但他们真正看到的第一件事其实是这种升腾的烟柱，以及从山中喷涌而出的气云。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为小普林尼（他是老普林尼的侄子）当时确实把这写了下来，否则我们根本一无所知。所以我们有一份关于这次火山爆发非常棒的目击记录。是的，这股由灰烬和气体组成的烟柱升到了大约——我想大概有30公里高的空中，然后自身发生坍塌。也就是在那时，我们迎来了大量的浮石雨，
um because it's probably the most famous volcanic explosion in history isn't it uh yeah I would I would go with that uh yeah so uh the whole eruption took sort of 24 hours I think in total uh so it was kind of a bit of a slow burner, which is why, you know, we find, I think, so many people still there because people kept thinking, we'll be OK, we'll be OK. But the first thing they saw really was this kind of column of smoke coming and a cloud of gas coming out of the out of the mountain. And we know about this because Pliny the Younger, who was the nephew of Pliny the Elder, was actually writing about this at the time, otherwise we wouldn't have a clue. So we have a really nice eyewitness account of this eruption. And yeah, this column of ash and gases rose up to about, I think it was about 30 kilometres up into the air and then collapsed on itself. And that's when we kind of get all the pumice stone raining down,
开始覆盖这座城市。但这个过程持续了很长时间。我的意思是，人们经历了几个小时这样的情况，心里想着：“也许我们会没事的。”然后，随着火山碎屑在城里不断堆积，物质逐渐——那么，这之前发生过吗？换句话说，也就是——是的，所以当人们认为“这可能会过去”或者“这会有点麻烦，但我们会挺过去”时，他们并不是完全疯了。他们认为——我的意思是，上一次（喷发）已经是将近2000年前的事了。
starting to cover the city. But this takes so long. I mean, there's sort of hours of this that people are kind of, well, maybe we'll be all right. And then, you know, as it builds up in the town and the material kind of gradually so had this happened had this happened before so in other words i mean in terms yes so people when they thought it's probably going to go away or it'll be a bit of a pain but we'll get over it they weren't being completely demented they thought they didn't i mean the previous one was sort of nearly 2,000 years beforehand.
但火山肯定曾经发出过轰鸣，并喷出过东西。是的，他们根本没有“火山喷发”的概念。他们有地震的概念。他们经历过很多地震，而且他们非常清楚，你知道的，他们处于一个不稳定的地区，但他们毫无头绪，甚至没有一丝一毫关于火山喷发的概念。甚至老普林尼，这位自然史先生，其实也并不认为维苏威火山是一座火山。
But the volcano must have rumbled and thrown stuff. Yeah, they had no concept of an eruption. They had concepts of earthquakes. They had a lot of earthquakes, and they were well aware that, you know, they were in an unstable area, but they had no clue, not an inkling as to the idea of an eruption. And even Pliny the Elder, who is Mr. Natural History, he didn't really even think that Vesuvius was a volcano anyway.
所以，我的意思是，你知道的，连那些懂行的人都不知道。普林尼弄错了，肖恩。没错，这就是头条新闻。他以为那是什么？只是一座有很多烟的山吗？这在名字里就有所体现，不是吗？因为故事是这样的：大力神海格力斯——我确信我们以前在很多播客里都聊过他，多米尼克——故事是说他来到意大利，然后巨人们对诸神进行叛乱，于是他把巨人们塞到了维苏威火山底下。所以人们的看法是，巨人们在里面扭动、颤抖和
So, I mean, you know, not even the people in the know knew. Pliny gets it wrong, Sean. Exactly, there's the headline. What did he think it was, just a mountain with a lot of smoke? It's there in the names, isn't it? Because the story is is that hercules the great hero who i'm sure we've talked about before dominic on many podcasts about um the story is that he he comes to italy and uh the giants are rebellious against the gods and so he shoves them underneath vesuvius and so the idea is that they're kind of twitching and shaking and
抽搐，这一定就是地震的原因。从而引发了地震。是的。赫库兰尼姆（Herculaneum）就是以赫拉克勒斯（Heracles）的名字命名的，据说他还举行过一次凯旋游行，在希腊语中叫做“庞贝”（Pompeii），这也是庞贝这个名字据说的来源。所以当时一定有某种想法……是的。
convulsing that must be the sort of earthquake. Which generates the earthquake. Yeah. And Heracles gives his name to Herculaneum, and he's supposed to have had a victory procession, which in Greek is Pompeii, which is supposedly where the name Pompeii comes from. So there must have been some kind of idea that... Yeah.
潜在的危险是存在的。但正如你所说，我的意思是，对于接下来会发生什么，（他们）完全没有概念。从“大地稍微摇晃一下”到……是的。而且现在人们也住在地震带上，不是吗？我的意思是，人们住在洛杉矶、伊斯坦布尔或者……完全正确。而且他们现在也住在火山脚下。而且，你知道的，当我住在那里的时候，我在那里实实在在地住了四年。所以我开始了解（你知道的）当地人。
Potentially there was danger. But as you say, I mean, no idea about what came next. It's a long stretch from, you know, the earth shaking a bit to... Yeah. And people live in earthquake zones now, don't they? I mean, people live in LA or Istanbul or... Exactly. And they live under volcanoes now too. And, you know, it was when I lived there, I lived there solidly for four years. So I got to know, you know, the locals.
对于在火山爆发期间是留在城里还是离开，当地人的态度可以说是泾渭分道。当然，他们中的有些人实际上经历过上一次火山爆发，那是发生在1944年。所以他们心里大概有数，你知道的，他们知道潜在的灾难就在那里，但他们并不准备离开。那是他们的家，你知道的。那是他们打算待下去的地方。
And it was a real split camp on whether people would stay in the city during an eruption or not. And, of course, some of them had actually lived through the last eruption, which was in 1944. So they kind of knew, you know, and they know that there were sort of potential disaster, but they weren't prepared to leave. That was their home, you know. That was where they were going to stay.
然后我找到了一些骑着摩托车、拼命逃命的朋友。那就是，你知道的，那就是我——我一直和这些朋友在一起。苏菲，能给我们讲讲在火山爆发之前庞贝的规模和重要性吗？所以它，它距离——我的意思是，那时的那不勒斯大概是一个更大的地方吧，对吧，尼亚波利斯（Neapolis）？是的，尼亚波利斯，完全正确。它算是一个——一个度假小镇，还是一个集镇？它更像是一个港口小镇。
And then I found some friends who were on a motorbike and getting the hell out. And that's, you know, that's what I, those are the friends I stuck with. And give us some sense, Sophie, of the sort of size and importance of Pompeii before the eruption happened. So is it, it's not that far from, I mean, Naples was presumably a bigger place then, was it, Neapolis? Yes, Neapolis, exactly. And was it a sort of – was it a resort town, a market town? It's more of a port town.
所以赫库兰尼姆更像是那种度假胜地。是的，而庞贝很大程度上是一个工人阶级小镇。但很有意思的是，人们总是说：“哦，庞贝就是一个标准得不能再标准的普通小镇。它就像是——”我不记得是谁说的了，但有人这么说过。雷丁（Reading），对吧？完全正确。诸如此类。萨弗伦沃尔德（Saffron Walden），我觉得有人把它跟这联系起来过。
So Herculaneum is more the kind of resort. Yeah, and Pompeii was very much a kind of working town. But it's interesting because people always say, well, Pompeii is a kind of bog standard town. It's like – I can't remember who said it, but someone said it. Reading, isn't it? Exactly. Something like that. Saffron Walden, I think it's been connected.
但我真的不觉得是这样。我的意思是，我在罗马帝国各地旅行过相当广泛的区域。而且我认为实际上，就其本身而言，它是一个相当了不起的地方。工匠的水平，这个地方的组织结构——我认为它实际上是一个非常特殊的地方。但它确实——它的核心是一个港口小镇，而且它历史悠久，不是吗？我的意思是，这是一个历史悠久的地方，它——是的，它的历史早于罗马人，早于希腊人。这里有一群被称为奥斯坎人（Oscans）的人，他们在那里定居，然后——嗯，实际上，苏菲，你和我都知道这一点，因为苏拉这位可怕的
But I don't really think it is. I mean, I've traveled quite extensively around the Roman Empire. And I think it's actually, on its own, it's quite an astounding place. The level of craftsmanship, the sort of the organization of the place i think it's it was actually quite a special place but it was yeah the main hub of it was it was a port town and it's old isn't it i mean it's an old place it's kind of yeah proceeds the romans precedes the greeks you've got these people called oscars who are who are settling there and then um well actually sophie you and i know this because um sulla the the terrifying
共和派将军，他是第一个率军向罗马进军的人，他之所以拥有这些军队，是因为意大利人针对罗马的统治发起了某种起义，正是苏拉——嗯，本质上对庞贝进行了围攻和强攻，他的投石机在城墙上留下的弹痕至今仍然清晰可见。上次你带我去庞贝的时候，你还特意指给我看过。所以这绝对是一个亮点：那里至今仍然保留着一台投石机，他们找到了它——我的意思是，它看起来真的很像一颗炸弹。是的，那会造成相当大的破坏。真是个令人惊叹的景象。而且——然后苏拉的军队被安插在那里，它变成了一个殖民地。所以从某种意义上说，在——你知道的——不到两个世纪的时间里，到毁灭发生的时候，它
republican general who is the first to march on rome the reason he has these armies is because the italians have kind of risen in revolt against roman rule and it's sulla who um essentially besieges and storms pompeii and the um the crater marks on the walls left by his catapults can still be seen and the last time you took me to pompeii you pointed them at me so it's an absolute highlight there is one catapult that still still exists they found it just i mean it does look like a a bomb really yeah that's going to do some damage kind of amazing amazing sight and um and then and then salop his his troops get planted there and it becomes a colony so in a sense you know within kind of you know less than two centuries by the time of the destruction it's
是一个殖民地——它已经被罗马人殖民了，它被罗马人攻占了，它被罗马人殖民了，所以它实际上是一个混合体。是的，绝对是这样。而这就是让我恼火的地方——我那小小的（你知道的）我愿意为之赴死的微小执念之一，就是人们说它是一个“时间胶囊”，被时间定格了。我的意思是，好吧，当它刚刚经历了一场火山爆发时，你真的不能说它是“定格”的。但这种“时间胶囊”的说法，就好像它在某个特定时刻完美地保存了某些东西一样，真的让我很烦恼，因为它拥有可以追溯到公元前6世纪左右的历史。整座城市就像是所有这一切的一个重写本（palimpsest）。它是——你知道的，就像大多数城市一样，它们是——你知道的，有较旧的部分，也有较新的部分。对我而言，它根本不符合那种“时间胶囊”的时刻。
it's a collar it's been colonized by the Romans it's been stormed by the Romans it's been colonized by the Romans and so it is a kind of hybrid place yeah no absolutely and this is what aggravates me my little you know one of my mini heels that I'll go and die on is that people say it's a time capsule, frozen in time. I mean, well, you can't really say frozen when it's just undergone an eruption. But this kind of time capsule thing as if it's preserving something absolutely at a specific time, it really kind of annoys me because it has got this history that goes back to the sort of 6th century BC. And the whole city is a kind of palimpsest of all of this. It's, you know, as most cities are, they're sort of, you know, there's older bits, there's newer bits. And it doesn't really fit in that sort of time capsule moment for me at all.
所以它并不是一个关于“罗马特色”的特定定格时刻？绝对不是。不，对我来说不是。那那里有多少人——我的意思是，有多少人，那里的每个人都会认为自己是罗马人吗？差不多吧，是的。所以它不像是一个大熔炉，是吗？嗯，我的意思是，它是。但随后，你知道，要成为罗马公民，你就是罗马公民，无论你来自叙利亚还是其他什么地方。所以从这个意义上说，是的——我的意思是，然后显然有大量的奴隶，他们不被认为是公民之类的，所以这里（你知道的）
So it's not a particular frozen moment of kind of Roman-ness? Absolutely not. No, not to me. And how many of the people there would have been, I mean, how many of the people, would everybody there have considered themselves Romans? More or less, yeah. So it wasn't a sort of a melting pot, as it were? Well, I mean, it is. But then, then you know to be a roman citizen you you were a roman citizen whether you came from syria right wherever so in that sense yes i mean then there's obviously there's a lot of slaves who were not considered citizens and stuff so there's you know
这里仍然是一个大熔炉。不过，不过——那个印度女神的雕像还在吗，就是传统上被称为拉克什米（Lakshmi）的那尊？那尊那不勒斯考古博物馆里的印度女神雕像。是的。我不认为那是拉克什米。不，不是。是另一个。我被纠正过，传统上人们是这么叫她的。是另一个，但是是的，我记不起名字了。
there's it is still a melting pot but but but the system is the indian goddess isn't there who is conventionally called lakshmi the statue The statue of the Indian goddess in the Naples Archaeological Museum. Yes. I don't think it is Lakshmi. No, it's not. It's the other one. I'm being told off that traditionally that's what she's called. It's the other one, but yes, the name escapes me.
但我的意思是，这也是它的迷人之处，不是吗？你能感受到那些生活在那里的人们的存在，而这些人通常不会出现在宏大历史叙事的记录中。因此，讲述那些否则我们可能无法了解的阶层人们的故事是可能的。这也是你特别感兴趣的方面，不是吗？是的，不，对我而言，而且我认为——你知道的，这在最近变得非常流行——那就是把目光从皇帝和主要的市政建筑上移开。
But I mean, that is also the fascination of it, isn't it? That you get the sense of peoples who lived there who don't normally show up in the kind of historical records for the Grand Sweep. And so it is kind of possible to tell the stories of the kinds of class of people who otherwise we might not be able to. That's something that you're particularly interested in, isn't it? Yeah, no, for me, and I think, you know, it's become really popular more recently is to edge away from the emperors and the main civic buildings.
你知道的，我们了解神庙，我们了解巴西利卡（长方形会堂）以及所有这些东西。但庞贝为你提供了一个——令人惊叹的、绝佳的机会去了解日常生活，了解一个小酒馆的老板、一个经营洗衣店的人，然后——那些隐形的奴隶也随之鲜活起来，因为你实际上可以开始想象他们在工作时的样子。他们没有留下太多痕迹，但你突然发现，这座城市之所以能运转，完全离不开背后由奴隶组成的“发动机舱”式的支撑。我想这就是庞贝带给我的感受：一束巨大的光突然照亮了社会上那些通常无法进入历史书的成员。
You know, we know about temples, we know about basilica and all of that stuff. But Pompeii gives you, you know, amazing, amazing opportunity to see everyday life and the person who owns a bar the person who runs uh a laundrette um and then the sort of the invisible slaves kind of come to life as well because you can actually start imagining them you know at work they don't leave many traces behind but you can suddenly see this city is only going to function with you know an engine room type thing of slaves behind it and i think that's what pompeii gives me is suddenly this sort of huge light is cast on those members of society that don't normally kind of get into the history books.
所以让我问你这个问题。作为一名现代历史学家，当我参观很多这样的遗址时，总是会有一种轻微的失落感，因为那里只剩下一堆石头。所以当我拉着我儿子去的时候，我说：“这里有一个最了不起的罗马……”你就是猫途鹰（TripAdvisor）上那种游客。是的，正好。因为那里只有一堆石头。所以当我拉着我儿子去，跟他说“这里有最了不起的罗马遗址”时，他经常会问：“真的有城墙吗，还是真的只是一排石头？”某种程度上这确实是事实：当你去参观这些遗址时，你希望能融入罗马世界，但结果却只是一些建筑。不过庞贝
So let me ask you this question. So as a modern historian, when I go to a lot of these sites, there's always this slight element of being underwhelmed because there's a pile of stones. So when I dragged my son and I said, there's this most amazing Roman... You're that guy on TripAdvisor. Yeah, exactly. Wilm because there's a pile of stones. So when I dragged my son and I said, there's this most amazing Roman site, he often says, is there actually a wall or is it really just a line of stones? And there's some sort of degree of truth in that is that you go to these sites and you're hoping to get into the Roman world and and it is just buildings but Pompeii
显然不同，因为每个人从庞贝带走的、最标志性的东西，就是那些逃离火山爆发的人们的石膏像。所以你实际上能看到那些人，但你看到的是他们被定格——或者更准确地说，我猜是被烘烤在痛苦的瞬间、死亡的瞬间。在哪个节点上，这会有点越界呢？我的意思是，在任何其他——在任何近期发生的自然灾害中，你都不会说：“哦，让我们去看所有死难者的尸体吧。”所以你是怎么看待这一点的？你觉得这——当然，你知道，游客们非常喜欢它，但你觉得这没问题吗？我在这件事上有点骑墙。我觉得，很显然，游客们非常喜欢它，但你觉得这没问题吗？
is obviously different because the one thing that everybody gets from Pompeii are they the plaster casts of the people fleeing the explosion so you see the effectively see the people but you see them frozen or rather kind of I guess baked in the moment of agony in the moment of their death and at what point does that sort of cross a bit of a line? I mean, you wouldn't do that in any other, in any sort of recent natural disaster, you wouldn't say, oh, let's go and look at all the corpses of the people who died. So how do you, how do you kind of feel about that? Do you think it's, I mean, obviously, you know, the visitors love it, but do you feel it's okay? I sort of sit on a bit of a fence on that. I think, obviously, you know, the visitors love it, but do you feel it's OK?
我在这件事上有点骑墙。从伦理上讲，我觉得这有点窥阴癖的意味，这让我觉得稍微有点不舒服。但与此同时，它确实给我们、也给庞贝带来了那种极其真切的、感同身受的发生感。这座城市曾充满生机，而他们确实遭受了苦难。我觉得，如果没有这些石膏像，只看到一些骨头，它就不会具备那种同样的冲击力。作为考古学家和游客，我们总是觉得我们需要那种连接感，或者需要与某些事物产生共鸣以便更好地理解它。我想，至少对我来说，这些石膏像提供的正是这种东西。
I sort of sit on a bit of a fence on that. I think ethically I feel it is a bit voyeuristic and it makes me a little bit uncomfortable. But at the same time, it has given us and it's given Pompeii that real sort of visceral sense of what happened. And the city was populated and they did suffer. And I think without them being cast and just seeing, you know, some bones, I don't think it has that same power. And as archaeologists and tourists, we always feel we need that connection or to relate to something to better understand it. And I think that's what they provide for me anyway.
那里还有狗和马。我知道，还有一头猪。有一头猪。简直太惊人了。完全正确。不。所以，苏菲，我有一点很好奇——这些东西，它们其实不是尸体，对吧？
There are dogs and horses. I know, there's a pig. There's a pig. Kind of amazing. Exactly. No. So, Sophie, one thing I wonder about that, that the way that these, they're not bodies, are they?
我的意思是，那些石膏像，是那些被焚烧的人留下来的空腔。人们似乎有一种巨大的冲动，想要把各种叙事和故事强加到他们身上。这其实挺有趣的。去年不是有一个著名的——是去年吗？有一张照片，一个人身上压着一块石头，大家都觉得非常搞笑。但你也会听到关于女性去看角斗士比赛以及诸如此类的各种故事。现在，这是一种浪漫化的投射，不是吗？我的意思是，当你仔细审视这些故事的证据时，它们几乎总是经不起推敲，有点不攻自破。
I mean, the plaster casts, the kind of the gaps that these incinerated people had left. There seems to be a huge temptation to impose narratives and stories onto them. So it can be kind of quite fun. There was this kind of famous, was it last year? There was a picture of a body with a rock that had fallen on it that everyone found very funny. But you also get stories about women going to see gladiators and all this kind of stuff. Now, that is a kind of romantic projection, isn't it? I mean, the evidence for these stories, when you look at them closely, almost always tends to kind of slightly fall to pieces.
是的。嗯，这又回到了我们总是试图产生共鸣、试图把它们变成我们能理解的事物，或者为它们编织一个故事，好让我们在情感上产生联系。是的，有那个怀孕女人的石膏像——或者其实只是她衣服拱起了一部分，造成了一个隆起的假象？我们并不确定……所以，是的，我认为试图编造这些故事对我们来说是一种非常自然的冲动。然后，正如你所说，过了一段时间，你知道的，他们对石膏像进行了扫描，结果发现实际上那个女人是个男人，或者反过来……嗯，我想其中有一个（石膏像）原本被认为是个“摩尔人”，结果证明其实是个14岁左右的当地男孩，只不过刚好骨架稍微大了一些。所以，是的，这些故事确实被打破了，但与此同时，这也是如此自然。当我在遗址现场每天都这样做时，你知道的，我会为我的酒保编造一些小故事，因为这有助于让生活继续下去。不过同样地，我可不是来扫兴的，这里确实有 amazing（惊人）的故事，
Yes. Well, that's that kind of goes back to us always trying to relate and to make them something that we understand or give them a story so that we feel emotionally attached um and yes there's the the cast of the pregnant woman um or is it just a bit of her clothing that's ridden up and has given her a bulge and you know we're not sure um uh so yes i think it's a really a natural sort of idea for us to try and make these stories and then yes as you say later on you know they scan the cast and they find out that actually that woman was a man or the other way around um uh i think there was one that was supposed to be it was called the more and it turned out to be a local lad of 14 or something
你可以通过它们——或许不是通过尸体，而是通过涂鸦和——完全正确，从这些地方推断出来。所以，能分享几个你最喜欢的这类例子吗？嗯，我最喜欢的一个是——呃，这个人叫盖乌斯·埃利乌斯·尼吉迪乌斯·马尤斯（Gaius Julius Nigidius Maius）。我喜欢他是因为，在我看来，他体现了我们在庞贝是如何了解这些普通人的。我们不会走进他们的房子，翻翻他们的书桌抽屉，然后找到一堆文件，确切地告诉我们他在这一天在做什么之类的信息。你知道的，我们在庞贝没有这种东西。而且我认为人们会以为事情就是这样的：你找到了某个人的房子，然后你就自动知道了他们所有人都在忙些什么。这个人的房子是在1810年被发现的，我想是的。所以是在发掘工作开始的早期阶段。他们发现他的
who just happened to be a bit bigger framed. So, yes, they did get unravelled, but at the same time, it's so natural. And when I do it every day on site, you know, I would make up little stories about my barman because it kind of helps kind of tick it along. But equally, not to be a party pooper, there are amazing stories
名字被画在墙上，上面写着：“这是我的房产，我想把它租出去。所以关于租房的事，去找我的奴隶普里穆斯（Primus）吧。”这就是我们当时对他的了解。后来情况逐渐明朗，收养他的家族非常富有，因为他们在城外拥有墓地。大约一百年后，你知道的，在庞贝的另一侧，发掘工作仍在继续，他们发现墙上有一些彩绘告示，
that you can extrapolate perhaps not from the bodies but from the graffiti and from the exactly so on so so just give a couple of your favorite examples of that uh i think one of my favorites is um this uh this man called gaius alias nigidius maus. And I like him because he kind of embodies to me how we find out about these people in Pompeii. We don't go into their houses and rummage through their sort of desk drawers and find a whole load of documents that tell us exactly what he was doing on this day or whatever. You know, we don't have that in Pompeii. And I think people think that that's how it works is, you know, you find the house of someone and you automatically know what they're all up to. And this guy who, they discovered his house in 1810, I think. So very early on in the beginning of the excavations. And they found his
上面告诉我们尼吉迪乌斯·马尤斯正在负责组织圆形剧场竞技比赛。所以我们突然穿越回了一百年后，看到了——你知道的——这个人，“哦，我记得他在那边呢。”然后我们发现，他组织比赛的时间很可能是正值禁令期间——当尼禄在公元59年禁止举办竞技比赛之后，
name painted on the wall and said, this is my property, I want to let it out. So see my slave Primus about, you know, renting it. And that's what we knew about him. Then it kind of transpired that his family who had adopted him was very rich because they've got tombs outside the town. And then about a hundred years later, you know, on the other side of Pompeii, excavation is continuing and they find some painted notices on the wall,
因为他开始举办比赛，但比赛中没有角斗士，因为比赛被禁了，原因是发生过骚乱，尼禄很生气。然后时间快进到——我想大约是2018年。又一个一百年过去了，他们在城市南部发现了一座陵墓，并找到了一个巨大的长篇铭文。大家都兴奋极了，除了上面没有名字。
which tell us that Negidius Maius is in charge of organising the amphitheatre games. So we suddenly get a flashback 100 years later to sort of, you know, this guy, yes, I remember him from over there. And then we find out that he was organising games probably during the ban, when Nero banned the games from AD 59,
所以它仍然是个空白。但在铭文中，他们记录了这场盛大宴会的细节——他是为超过——嗯，差不多7,000人举办了一场宴会。但上面还说，他是尼禄禁令期间竞技比赛的组织者。所以这很可能就是他的墓。整篇铭文有点类似于奥古斯都的《神的功业录》（Res Gestae）那种风格。
because he starts putting on games, but they don't have gladiators in them because they're banned because there was a riot and Nero got cross. And then spool forward to, I think it was about 2018. So another hundred years passes and they find a tomb in the south of the city and they find a huge long inscription. Everyone gets very excited, except there's no name on it.
这有点像是“我活着的时候做了什么”、“我取得了什么成就”以及“它们有多么伟大”。所以我们突然就有了这个男人的传记。但这花了200年时间，才从城里的三个不同地方拼凑起来。我只是觉得，你知道的，他的一生——他在镇上非常重要。他担任过你能担任的最高职位、最有声望的职位。但，是的，这个过程真的很慢。我觉得他对我来说就是这种过程的化身。我就是喜欢这种将碎片像拼图一样拼凑起来的感觉。
So it's still kind of a blank. But in the inscription, they've got details of this huge banquet that's put on for over, well, it's nearly 7,000 people he puts a banquet on for. But it also says he was the organiser of the games during the ban of Nero. So it's probably his tune. And this whole inscription is a bit sort of like the Reyes-Guestide type thing.
所以，多姆，他简直就是巴里·赫恩（Barry Hearn）。是的，或者确实是唐纳德·特朗普。这是一个有趣的观点，不是吗？他免费提供比赛。他是个好人。天下没有免费的午餐。不，不，不。
It's sort of what I did when I was alive and what I accomplished and how great they are. So then we've suddenly got a biography of this man. But this has taken 200 years to piece together from three different places in town. And I just think, you know, his life is, he was very important in the town. He had the highest office, the ranking office that you could have. But yeah, that's, the process is really slow. And I think that he embodies it for me. And I just kind of love that fragmentary sticking jigsaw pieces together.
有来有往，不是吗？苏菲，既然你已经把我这个在猫途鹰上抱怨一堆石头的家伙给出卖了，那我索性就彻底放飞自我吧。好吧，嗯，人们从庞贝带走的、人人皆知的另一件事就是色情艺术，对吧？我的意思是，这就是很多游客来看的东西，他们来看——他们期待看到人们以一种放荡的方式行事的马赛克壁画。是的。现在，我的问题分为两个部分。一是，我们是否夸大了这一点，还是说这在当时其实是常态？
So Dom, he's kind of Barry Hearn. Yes, or indeed Donald Trump. That's a nice thought, isn't it? He put games on free. He was nice. He was a nice guy. There's never a free lunch. No, no, no.
如果这真是常态，而且人们在他们的餐厅里摆放这种东西，这是否告诉我们罗马人与我们完全不同，他们的道德标准和一切都截然不同？还是说我夸大了、过度渲染了这一点？不，我觉得你说得完全切中要害。我觉得——嗯，这种现象非常普遍。当他们在18世纪中期刚开始发掘时，发掘人员惊恐地发现，庞贝的各阶层到处都是生殖器符号。不仅仅是——你知道的——在精英阶层中，也不仅仅是——你知道的——那些淘气的小酒馆老板之类的人。
There's a quid pro quo, isn't there? Sophie, since you've already outed me as the man man on trip advisor who complains about a pile of stones might as well go all in okay um the other thing that people take away from pompeii that everybody knows about is the erotic art right i mean that's what a lot of tourists come to see they come to see they expect to see mosaics of sort of people, you know, behaving in a debauched way. Yes. Now, my question is sort of twofold. Is that, have we exaggerated that or was that kind of the norm?
它渗透到了社会的各个层面。他们感到绝对惊恐。他们把所有的材料都搬走，藏在波蒂奇（Portici）宫殿的博物馆里，因为他们根本不想让别人知道罗马人竟然如此不同——我的意思是，我说的是“我们”，但这已经是50年前的事了。这种隐藏东西的做法一直在继续。事实上，这后来就成了那不勒斯秘密博物馆的一部分，该博物馆直到2000年才对公众开放。直到那时，（这些内容）才被认为是可以接受的。所以，我的意思是，我们花了相当长的时间才真正接受色情内容。
And if it was the norm and people had that stuff in their kind of dining room, does that tell us that the Romans were completely unlike us and their sort of moral standards and everything were utterly different? Or am I exaggerating and overplaying that no i think you're spot on i think um it is really prevalent and when they first started excavating in the in the mid 18th century the excavators were horrified to find that there were phalluses um of sort of transcended every class in Pompeii. It wasn't just, you know, in the elite or it wasn't just the, you know, the naughty little sort of bar owners and things like that.
可以说。可以说是的。双关语不是有意为之的。事实上，我曾去过大英图书馆——我大概不应该点名批评它们，但我去大英图书馆是为了查阅一本关于庞贝色情艺术的书，它被贴上了某种“特殊处理”标签，我不得不去一个——
It pervaded all sort of society. And they were absolutely horrified. And they took all of the material away and hid it in a museum in the palace at Portage, because they just didn't want people to know that, you know, the Romans were so unlike, I mean, I say us, I mean, this is already 50 years ago. And that carried on, you know, hiding this stuff. And in fact, which then became the secret museum in Naples, which only opened to the public in 2000. That's when it was kind of deemed okay. So, I mean, it's taken us quite a long time to get to grips with the pornography.
不允许拍照的柜台，上面贴着诸如“严禁拍照”之类的大贴纸。这实际上只是一本我们在互联网上随处可见的壁画的咖啡桌画册。但我只是觉得这相当滑稽，在2019年或者无论什么时候，它居然依然受到这种禁令的限制。但事实确实如此。它无处不在。而且我觉得他们确实——所以能给我讲讲吗？
As it were. As it were, yes. No pun intended. In fact, I went to the British Library. I probably shouldn't name and shame them, but I went to the British Library to look at one of the erotic art books of Pompeii and it was under sort of special handling label or something and I had to go and I had to go to a desk where I
基本上，如果你在庞贝长大，或者在那个时期的任何罗马城镇长大，你随时随地都被这些东西包围着，对吧？从童年到——你知道的，这并不是说小约翰尼和伟大姑妈玛乔丽因为年龄不对、觉得不太合适而看不到的东西。这总是合适的吗？这是一种——我觉得还是有一定界限的。我的意思是，有许多关于粗俗片段的语境。很显然，你有妓院——孩子们可能不会去妓院，但在私人住宅内部，你知道的，色情
wasn't allowed to take photographs it had you know a big sort of stickers on it saying don't take photos and it was literally a coffee table book of the frescoes that we see on the internet all the time but I just thought this is quite hilarious that still, you know, in 2019, whenever it was, that it was still under this kind of ban. But no, it was. It was everywhere. And I think they did. So give me some sense.
图片主要分布在更私密的区域，尽管有些确实在中庭——那是所有人都可以去的地方。但随后你也会有诸如刻有阴茎的牌匾，用来祈求好运——所以这有一种完全不同的含义。而且这是所有人都能看到的。它们在街角，在你的门楣上，在风铃上，在灯具上。我的意思是，是的，你甚至在童年时期就会看到生殖器符号，绝对会。我觉得庞贝因为这个原因而显得相当压抑，因为很容易
So basically, if you grew up in Pompeii or indeed any Roman town in that time, you were surrounded by this stuff all the time, right? From childhood to, you know, it wasn't something that little Johnny and great-aunt Marjorie don't get to see because they're the wrong age and it's not appropriate. It's always appropriate? Was that the kind of... I think there were slight boundaries. I mean, there's lots of context for sort of rude bits and pieces. Obviously, you've got the brothel, which, which you know kids probably wouldn't be going to um but inside private houses you know they're mainly the erotic
让人觉得到处都是巨大的生殖器符号。是的，但事实上，儿童在房屋内和妓院里确实会遭受性虐待。我的意思是，他们——你知道的——这是完全合法的。当走进庞贝、看到奴隶被迫生活的空间时，我的感受是——你知道他们其实就是可以被任何人——任何拥有他们的人随意处置的牺牲品。你会感受到，作为被奴役者、作为持续性虐待的受害者，那种生活会有多么可怕——而这种持续的性虐待显然构成了庞贝性经济的基础。所以我认为，参观庞贝的矛盾之处在于，它被营销为——
pictures are mainly in the more private areas although there's some are in sort of the atrium which is where everyone can go um but then you've got things like the plaques with penises on for um sort of good luck so that has a a completely different sort of idea about it. And that was seen by everybody. They were on street corners, they were above your door, they were on wind chimes, lamps. I mean, yeah, you would see a phallic symbol even as a child, absolutely. I find Pompeii quite oppressive for that reason because it's tempting
一个你可以了解罗马人真实生活的地方，其潜台词是：“哦，看呐，他们跟我们一模一样。”但实际上，如果你深入观察，你会发现他们根本和我们一点也不一样。这是一种可怕的、截然不同的存在。基于这一点，我想我们也许应该休息一下。当我们回来时，也许……我以为你要在那儿宣传你的书呢，汤姆。那是显而易见的。我正要这么做。我正要这么做。我能看出你脑子里在想这个。
to fight going in a t he huge fallacies everywhere yeah but i mean actually children would have been sexually abused um in in houses and in brothels i mean they were you know they're perfectly legitimate and what what i feel when you go to pompeii and you look at the spaces in which the slaves were obliged to live and you you know that they are kind of free game for whoever is free, whoever owns them. And you feel how horrendous it must have been to be owned, to be kind of subject to the kind of sustained sexual abuse that clearly is providing the the sexual economy of of Pompeii with its its foundations and so I think that one of the one of the tensions in going to Pompeii is that it is marketed as um uh something where you can see how the Romans really lived and the implication is oh look they were just like us but actually I think if you look more deeply you find
我正要这么做。我能感觉得到那种无声的失望顺着电话线向我袭来。所以，不，我不打算宣传我的书——该书可在各大优质书店购买。我们去休息一下，等我们回来时，也许我就可以宣传了。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《余烬即娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐
they weren't like us at all it It was kind of terrifyingly different. On which note, I think perhaps we should go for a break. And when we come back, maybe... I thought you were going to plug your book there, Tom. That was the obvious. I was about to. I was about to. I could see you thinking of it.
新闻、评论、一抹好莱坞八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到我的节目《历史的余烬》，我是主持人，今天的嘉宾是汤姆·霍兰德和苏菲·海博士，她来这里是为了聊聊庞贝。汤姆，我们收到了来自推特上网友的大量提问。我先从马克·伍德哈斯（Mark Woodhouse）的问题开始。他说，他基本上只想直奔主题。他想知道，最近的发掘中最重要的发现是什么？你觉得那里还剩下什么？还有什么在等待被发掘呢，苏菲？
I was about to. And I could sense the disappointment unspoken coming at me down the line. So no, I'm not going to plug my book, which is available from all good bookshops. Let's go for a break and when we come back, maybe I can plug it then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment
所以，是的，新的发掘工作绝对是——我的意思是，对我来说简直是匪夷所思。我对庞贝发现的所有东西其实都相当熟悉了。但看着这些东西从地下显现出来，我的眼睛也和所有人一样瞪得老大。
news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to uh my show Rest Is History, with my guests Tom Holland and Dr Sophie Hay, who's here to talk about Pompeii. We have a ton of questions, Tom, from people on Twitter. I'm going to kick off with Mark Woodhouse. He says, he just wants to cut to the chase, basically. He says he wants to know what is the most significant find
不过应该带上某种警告说明，解释这些发掘工作为什么会展开，因为我觉得人们只是以为他们一直在盲目挖掘，而没有去保护现有的东西。事实上，这其实是一个更大项目的一部分，该项目获得了欧盟资金的支持，其主要目的是让发掘现场的边坡保持稳定。所以它本质上是一个保护项目，但它包含了一个发掘元素——当他们向后退缩发掘面时，他们实际上确实在房屋里进行挖掘。但，是的，绝对令人惊叹。而且我确实认为，最近发现的那个酒吧——酒吧——可能是有史以来最重要的发现之一，因为它将我们的认知带到了超越以往的地方。
from the recent excavations and what do you reckon is there? What is left? What's waiting to be dug up, Sophie? So, yeah, no, the new excavations have been absolutely, I mean, just mind-boggling to me. And I'm quite used to all of, you know, the things that are found in Pompeii. But I have been as googly-eyed as everybody else watching these things kind of appear out the
而很多其他的东西，尽管它们同样惊艳。为什么会这样，苏菲？是因为发现的材料吗？比如在陶罐里发现的食物？是的，不，完全是因为这个。这是第一次——他们这样说完全正确——我们可以以绝对专业的方式进行发掘，并且可以动用各种高科技手段：他们有动物考古学家、有古植物学家来研究陶罐内部的残留物。因此，他们在陶罐里发现了一块鸭骨头——这实际上是我们在庞贝的酒吧里，第一次在陶罐里发现骨头。
ground and there should be some kind of um caveat saying that why these excavations took place because I think people are just believing that they're going ahead digging without conserving what they've got and in fact this is all part of a of a bigger project um that was given eu funding to to basically make the sides of the excavation stable um so it's a conservation project but it's got an element as they kind of step back the side of the excavation there they are actually digging in houses um but yeah no absolutely stunning and i do actually think that the the most recent find of the of the bar right um bar is probably one of the most important because it takes us beyond what we knew before.
食物是在这些嵌入酒吧内部的下沉式陶瓷容器中被发现的。而在我们所知道的以前所有的例子中，或者在我们所拥有的任何证据中，发现的总是干粮。所以我们一直有一种印象，认为（酒吧）供应的都是干粮，而突然之间，我们的认知被彻底颠覆了。
Whereas a lot of the other things, although they're stunning. And why does it do that, Sophie? Because of the material found, the food that was found actually in the pots? Yeah, no, absolutely. For the first time, and they're quite right in saying that, we can dig something absolutely properly and they can throw technology at it they've got the zoo archaeologists they've got archaeobotanists looking at the at the remains inside the pot so the fact that they found duck bone a duck bone inside the pot it's actually the first time that we've got a bone in a pot
然而许多其他东西，尽管它们令人惊叹。索菲，为什么会这样？是因为在罐子里发现了材料，实际上就是罐子里发现的食物吗？对，没错，绝对是的。这是第一次，他们说得完全对，我们可以真正彻底地发掘某样东西，他们可以把各种技术运用上去，有动物考古学家，有古植物学家研究罐子里面的遗存，所以他们在罐子里发现了鸭骨头这一事实，实际上是我们第一次在罐子里发现骨头
in a bar in pompeii um food has been found in these kind of sunken, sort of sunken ceramic vessels that are kind of encased within the bar. And all the previous ones that we know of or any evidence we've had is always dried food. So we've always had this thing that the, you know, they were serving dried food and suddenly we get shifted completely off
在庞贝的一家酒吧里，嗯，在这些嵌入酒吧内部的下沉式陶瓷容器中发现了食物。我们所知道的所有以前的发现或我们拥有的任何证据，总是不含水分的干食物。所以我们一直认为，你知道的，他们供应的是干食物，而突然之间我们的看法被彻底颠覆了
and we suddenly think, oh, actually they were producing hot food and it was being stored in these in these in these pots and we have i think there was a pork and fish dish so probably the first surf and turf dish that there was um in one pot the other the next pot is even worse you'd right and get pork and fish rather than snails fish and sheep soup or something snails
然后我们突然想到，噢，实际上他们当时是在制作热食，并且被存放在这些这些这些陶罐里，我们觉得——我想当时里面有一道猪肉和鱼肉的菜，所以这大概是人类历史上第一道“海陆双拼”菜吧，嗯，在一个陶罐里；另一个、接下来的陶罐就更糟了，你宁愿去吃猪肉和鱼肉，也不想吃蜗牛、鱼和羊肉汤什么的吧，蜗牛
fish and what sheep sheep yeah and then fish gut sauce exactly garum
鱼还有什么？羊，羊，对，然后还有鱼肠酱，没错，就是加勒姆鱼露
is that garum yeah well that's alright actually that's more like soy sauce so we can we can kind of let the garum
那是加勒姆鱼露吗？对，嗯，其实也还行，那东西其实更像是酱油，所以我们大概可以放过加勒姆鱼露一马
garum slide off but snail soup doesn't eat much I mean important to emphasise as well that it's off but but snail soup there's not much for me i mean important to emphasize as well that it's not just pompeii because there's also herculaneum which is yes the modern town of um is is built right on top of it and i i think um i'm right in remembering that um the house of the local mafia boss is over a crucial section of it yes so that's not going to happen and then of course there's the famous the villa of papyri isn't that exactly yeah the tantalizing possibility yeah no when i worked
让加勒姆鱼露的事就这么过去吧，不过蜗牛汤可就没那么好下咽了。我的意思是，也很重要的一点需要强调，那就是不仅仅只有庞贝，因为还有赫库兰尼姆，是的，现代城镇……呃，就建在它的正上方，而且我——我觉得……呃，我没记错的话，呃，当地黑手党老大的宅邸就压在它一个至关重要的遗址段落上面，对吧？所以那部分考古是没法进行了。当然，还有著名的纸莎草别墅，对吧？完全正确，是的，那种令人心痒难耐的可能性，是的。当年我在那里工作的时候
there they had demolished a whole series of houses and there was this sort of little island sticking up and and in it was the uh the mafia boss under house arrest um watching us doing our work so yeah so yeah so the roman patterns of patronage last into the 21st century exactly okay well here here's here's the here's the big question here's the big question it's from neil page are we any closer in getting consensus on a confirmed date for when vesuvius erupted okay and dominic as a as a historian of of modern britain i'm sure this embodies all your frustrations with ancient history that we don't even know don't even know when it happened are you are you able to give us the the kind of the rival as it were in a nutshell yes what the positions are okay so yes plinny
他们拆了一整排房子，然后留下了这么一个孤零零凸起的小岛，而黑手党老大就被软禁在这个岛上，看着我们干活。所以，是的，所以罗马式的庇护人制度一直延续到了21世纪。好吧，那么，这里有一个——这里有一个、这里有一个——这里有一个非常重要的问题，是尼尔·佩奇提的：我们在确定维苏威火山爆发确切日期的共识上，有没有取得任何进展？好吧，多米尼克，作为一个现代英国史学家，我确信这体现了你对古代史的所有沮丧感，那就是我们甚至不知道、甚至不知道它是什么时候发生的。你能不能给我们大致讲讲，长话短说，都有哪些针锋相对的观点？好吧，所以是的，普林尼
the younger um writing his we've got we've only got medieval copies of his writing so he wrote these letters um and he put in the date of the eruption that it happened thank you very much except the scribes so i don't blame plinny i blame the later scribes uh they couldn't quite read it it was in a bit of you know tattery state or something and so they just basically all made up different dates and inserted them so we have the 24th of august but we also have uh 30th of november or something and something in october and one in december i think so but the one that the sort of the copy of the letter that's the best preserved is the one that's got the 24th of august so that has basically become canon and that's the one that's banded
年轻的普林尼……写他的书信——我们现在只保留了他著作的中世纪抄本，所以他写了这些信，并且他在信中写下了火山爆发的日期——感谢上帝，非常感谢，除了抄写员们——所以我并不怪普林尼，我怪后来的抄写员们——他们当时有点认不清了，那份手稿当时处于一种破破烂烂的状态什么的，所以他们基本上就全都胡乱编造了不同的日期然后塞了进去。所以我们既有8月24日，但我们也有……呃，11月30日左右的日期，还有10月份的某个日期，我想还有一个是12月份的。但是，保存得最好的那份信件抄本上写的是8月24日，所以这个日期基本上就成了正统，也就是大家到处宣扬的
around then you kind of look at uh the archaeology and it kind of doesn't quite fit uh for the 24th of august so the main the main archaeological evidence against august is pomegranates. And I'm definitely team pomegranate. The fact you've got ripened pomegranates means it has to have been later in autumn. So they don't ripen and get eaten until end of September. So pomegranates are one. Then there's some really nice stuff actually from grapes because obviously you harvest grapes sort of october time and when one of the wine pressing rooms in pompeii was being dug um they found that kind of sludge still on the floor from
日期。然后当你去看看考古学证据时，又会发现它跟8月24日这个日期有点对不上。所以，反驳8月主要考古证据之一就是石榴。我绝对是“石榴派”的。你发现了成熟的石榴，这就意味着火山爆发的时间必定是在更晚的秋季。因为石榴要到9月底才会成熟并被人食用。所以石榴是一个证据。接下来还有一些来自葡萄的非常棒的证据，因为很显然你大概在10月份左右收获葡萄，当庞贝的一个榨酒作坊正在被发掘时，人们发现地板上仍然留着那种渣滓，那是来自于
from all the debris from from wine pressing and that wouldn't have been there in august i mean one would hope they'd have cleaned it up by then uh so yeah so yes do you have a sense of as is there a has the consensus swung now um i mean these things take time don't they it's like moving an oil tanker but do you think that it is a majority opinion now that it was in the autumn i think i think we'd all like to yes say that that is the case but people will still refer to the 24th of August. And then we had that graffito in the new excavations, in fact. So that's another really important thing. So what's that say? It's written in charcoal, and annoyingly
所有榨酒产生的残渣，如果是在8月份的话，这些东西是不会在那里的——当然，人们会希望他们到那时已经清理干净了。所以，是的——那么，你觉得目前的共识现在是否已经转变了？我的意思是，这种事情需要时间，对吧？就像掉头一艘超级油轮一样。但你认为，现在大多数人的主流观点已经认为它发生在秋季了吗？我想——我想大家都会乐意说，是的，事实确实如此，但人们仍然会引用8月24日。然后我们在新的发掘中发现了涂鸦，事实上，这也是另一个非常重要的东西。那上面写了什么？那是用木炭写的，而且真够烦人的
it has a date of the 17th of October. So everyone got super excited, saying, well, you can't write 17th of October if it's, you know, if it was all up in smoke in August. But of course there's no date. There's no year date. So it could have been.
上面写着10月17日的日期。所以每个人都兴奋极了，觉得：好吧，如果一切都在8月化为灰烬的话，你是不可能写下10月17日这种日期的。但当然，上面没有年份。所以它可能发生过。
And they could conceivably be. Your face is like, oh no. But they could conceivably also be writing, I'll see you next month. Well, indeed. Indeed, it could have been, yes. So there's, I mean, we have all these little tantalizing glimpses.
而且它们也可以想象成是……你的表情看起来像“哦不”。但它们也可以想象成是在写“下个月见”。嗯，确实。确实，完全可能是这样的。所以，我的意思是，我们有所有这些令人浮想联翩的小线索。
There was a coin as well that came up, which everyone said, this could only have been minted after the 24th of August. And it was found in a context that was completely safe, that there was no evidence of tampering. And yet, then it went to the British Museum,
还有一个出土的硬币，每个人都说，这枚硬币绝对只能是在8月24日之后铸造的。而且它是在一个完全安全的考古层位中被发现的，没有任何被人动过手脚的痕迹。然而，后来它被送到了大英博物馆
this coin got looked at, and they said, well, a bit that kind of gives you that sort of honorific title for Titus is actually really worn and you can't quite read it. You see, this is why you want to stick with Harrison. You don't get this kind of nonsense.
这枚硬币经过鉴定后，他们说：嗯，那个赋予提图斯某种荣誉头衔的部分实际上已经严重磨损了，你根本看不太清。你看，这就是为什么你想坚持读哈里森的著作。你不会遇到这种胡说八道。
Tony Benn's diaries. We don't even know the date of the big earthquake either. There's a huge earthquake and there's debate over that as well. We have two same dates and we don't know which is which. That brilliant kind of freeze showing all the buildings, tilting and toppling and things.
托尼·本的日记。我们甚至连那场大地震的日期都不知道。那是一场特大地震，对此也有争论。我们有两个相同的日期，却不知道哪个是哪个。那种展示所有建筑物倾斜、倒塌的精彩定格画面。
Exactly. But yeah, 62, 63, who knows? Dominic, do we have another question? Yeah, we do. Let me ask a question from Nathan. Nathan's got a very good question, actually. He's asking about the rediscovery of Pompeii and what people knew about it beforehand.
完全正确。不过，好吧，是公元62年还是63年，谁知道呢？多米尼克，我们还有其他问题吗？有的，我们有。让我问一个南森提的问题。南森提了一个非常好的问题，事实上。他问的是关于庞贝的重新发现，以及人们在此之前对它了解多少。
So in other words, had Pompeii completely been forgotten? Was there kind of local law um that survived through all the centuries that said there is something there that is covered there was this terrible tragedy you know did sort of folk tales persist or was this a sort of complete bolt from the blue when people started to uncover it uh one of the Bourbons who were digging it in 1748 would want you to believe that it was a complete bolt out of the blue and look at them, look what they discovered. Whereas actually in reality, it was known about the whole time,
换句话说，庞贝是被彻底遗忘了呢？还是说历经几个世纪流传下来某种地方传说，说那里有什么东西被埋在下面，曾发生过这样一场可怕的悲剧？你知道，民间传说是否一直存在？还是说当人们开始发掘它时，这完全是一个晴天霹雳？1748年参与发掘的波旁王朝的某个人，会想让你相信这完全是一个晴天霹雳，看看他们，看看他们发现了什么。而实际上，差不多
pretty much, I would say. Really? Yeah. So people had grown up for generations knowing that this stuff... Yeah, so it appears on a map that's 3rd, 4th century AD, and it's labelled on the Putinger map, so it's a map of Italy, and it's labelled as Pompeii there, as is Herculaneum, as is Oplontis, as is Stabale.
可以说，整个过程中人们其实一直都知道它的存在。真的吗？是的。所以好几代人都是伴随着这种认知长大的，他们知道这个地方……是的，它出现在一张公元3到4世纪的地图上，并且被标注在普廷格地图上，这是一张意大利地图，上面标出了庞贝，还有赫库兰尼姆、奥普隆蒂斯、斯塔比亚。
And then it becomes, sort of in the medieval period, it becomes known as La Civita. So it's a mound, it's still covered. And I mean, there's debate as to whether things were popping out or not in terms of buildings. But La Civita means the settlement. So it's kind of understood that there's something still under there. And if you plowing the ground all the time, because again, fertile soil, you know, things would pop out and bits of marble would come out. And so they did know all along.
然后在某种程度上，在中古时期，它被称为“奇维塔”（La Civita）。所以它是一个土丘，仍然被掩埋着。我的意思是，关于建筑物当时是否有部分露出来，还是没有露出来，一直存在争论。但“奇维塔”的意思就是定居点。所以人们心里明白，地下依然埋着某种东西。而且如果你一直在那片土地上耕作，因为那里土壤肥沃，你知道，有些东西就会冒出来，大理石碎片也会露出来。所以他们其实一直都知道。
It's just that it wasn't interesting to them there's uh sanazaro isn't it the um neapolitan poet writing at the beginning of the 16th century and yeah poem arcadia yes exactly he kind of says you know there are cities and towns and villas and things yeah no someone someone in 15 in 1594 said, because in 1594, they started digging a tunnel through Pompeii for a canal. And so they kept hitting, as they were digging through the mound, they kept hitting walls.
只是那对他们来说没什么吸引力。那里有……呃，萨纳扎罗，对吧？那位生活在16世纪初的那不勒斯诗人，他写过一首诗叫《阿卡迪亚》，是的，完全没错。他大致提到过，你知道，那里有城市、城镇和别墅之类的东西。没错，1594年的时候——因为在1594年，人们开始为修建一条运河而在庞贝地下挖一条隧道。所以在挖掘土丘的过程中，他们不断撞到墙壁。
And they sort of flagged it up and went, I think we're hitting something. And the people in charge were like, well, don't worry about it, keep going. Because it basically didn't adhere to the kind of the ideology of um the inquisition which was kind of that period um and any kind of reference to the past was was kind of politically incorrect sophia i wanted to i wanted to quiz you a bit on that you said that they didn't care about it they weren't interested can that really be true are you telling me that all these people just genuinely weren't,
他们把这事标记出来然后说：“我觉得我们撞上什么东西了。”而负责的人则说：“哦，别管它，继续挖。”因为这基本上不符合当时宗教裁判所的意识形态——那是那个时期的特征——任何对过去的提及在当时都被认为是在政治上不正确的。索菲，我想——我想就这一点稍微盘问你一下，你说过他们不在乎，他们对它不感兴趣，这真的可能是真的吗？你在告诉我，所有人真的都一点都不在乎吗？
they didn't care? Well, there wasn't that. I don't think there was that sort of fever for, I mean, to me Pompeii is always a very political thing. It's used for propaganda. It's used by the Bourbons to promote themselves. It's used by Napoleon. It's used by Mussolini.
嗯，当时并没有那种狂热——对我来说，庞贝一直是一个非常政治化的事物。它被用来进行政治宣传。它被波旁王朝用来提升自己的形象。它被拿破仑使用。它被墨索里尼使用。
You know, it's used during theoleon it's used by mussolini you know it's entire it's used during the period of um unification of italy you know to say who we are what we are as people you know it's always had a political edge so without that political edge there's kind of no real not even antiquarianism that didn't that wasn't i think it was i don't think it was it was it was too early for collecting a statue, basically. Yeah. I mean, that's my sort of hold on this. I think there's some evidence, isn't there, in the 16th and 17th century that people are kind of starting to ferret.
你知道，它在意大利统一时期被使用，你知道的，用来宣示我们是谁，我们作为一个人是什么样的。你知道，它一直带有政治色彩。所以如果没有这种政治色彩，那就没有什么真正的……甚至连古董收藏热都没有，那当时并不存在——我觉得，我觉得当时还为时过早，还不适合去收藏一尊雕像什么的。是的。我的意思是，我对这件事的看法就是这样。我觉得有一些证据表明，在16世纪和17世纪，人们其实已经开始四处搜寻了，不是吗？
I mean, I think it's, I think it's, I think it's kind of towards the end of the 17th century that somebody finds an inscription with Pompeii on it so that they then know that it's well they think it's at that point well no at that point they think it's the villa of Pompey the great so they confuse it and they're like well it's not as great and then they cross reference and exactly so no there's there is sort of interest amongst some but it's not it's not a big explosion of we've got to have the statuary and everything that happens. I mean, in Herculaneum, it starts beforehand. It starts at the beginning of the 18th century when a guy sinks his well over the theatre in Herculaneum
我的意思是，我觉得——我觉得——我觉得大约在17世纪末的时候，有人找到了一个刻有“庞贝”字样的铭文，然后他们才知道这是……好吧，他们当时以为那是……他们以为那是庞培大帝的别墅，所以他们搞混了，他们想：嗯，这好像没那么宏大。然后他们进行交叉比对，完全正确——所以，不，其中有些人确实表现出了一定兴趣，但这并不是那种“我们必须拥有雕像和一切”的大爆发。我的意思是，在赫库兰尼姆，发掘工作开始得更早。它始于18世纪初，当时有个家伙在赫库兰尼姆的剧院上方挖了一口井
and pulls out marble. And then there's an Austrian prince who decides, well, I'm building a villa. I'd quite like that marble on my walls, thanks. So he starts the process and then it kind of gets um exploded when when charles bourbon um kind of comes into town and says yes let's have all this stuff and builds a museum and the rest of it and then um lady hamilton's yes well yes he does a fair bit
并挖出了大理石。然后有一个奥地利亲王决定：“嗯，我正在建一座别墅。我很乐意把那些大理石贴在我的墙上，谢谢。”于是他开启了这个进程，然后当查理·波旁驾临此地并说“太好了，让我们把这些东西全都弄出来吧，再建一个博物馆以及其他一切”时，这个进程就彻底爆发了。然后……呃，汉密尔顿夫人的……是的，嗯，是的，他确实做了不少工作
he does a lot of work. We've got a question. We've already kind of touched on it, but maybe we could just, as it were, flesh it out. It's from the aptly named Ennius. And he says, in the light of recent discoveries, what would the typical daily diet of a resident of Pompeii and Herculaneum be? And I suppose that depends on what class of person I'll be talking about. Actually, it's quite interesting. Our good friend Andrew Wallace Hadwell dug a sewer in Herculaneum and the sewer goes underneath a range of houses and shops
他做了大量的工作。我们有一个问题。我们之前其实已经稍微涉及过了，但也许我们可以把它具体展开说说。这个问题来自名字很应景的恩尼乌斯。他问道：“根据最近的考古发现，庞贝和赫库兰尼姆居民的典型日常饮食会是什么样的？”我想这取决于我讨论的是哪个阶层的人吧。事实上，这相当有趣。我们的好朋友安德鲁·华莱士-哈德里在赫库兰尼姆发掘了一条下水道，这条下水道穿过了一系列房屋和店铺的下方
from very low class to slightly better. And he could see exactly what they were shitting out of each house. And in fact, the range of foods was was just like you'd find you know in an elite house they were having fresh fish i mean they live right on the coast uh seashells um meats different vegetables and their diet is actually sort of the one thing that's the great unifier in in in these towns i think um from his from this evidence. And then you've got all the frescoes of food, which kind of help us see what they were growing. I think, to me, the Pompeians and Herculaneum people
从非常低端的到底层稍微好一点的都有。他能够清楚地看到每一栋房子里排泄出来的东西。事实上，食物的种类——就像你在精英府邸里能找到的一样，他们吃新鲜的鱼，毕竟他们就住在海岸边；还有贝类、各种肉类、不同的蔬菜。从这些证据来看，他们的饮食实际上可以说是这些城镇中最大的凝聚力所在，我是这么认为的。然后你还有所有关于食物的壁画，这有助于我们了解他们在种植什么。在我看来，庞贝人和赫库兰尼姆人
were sort of perpetually eating. So if they weren't growing it themselves in their gardens, which they did a lot, and we have good excavations to show us what kind of, you know, they had cabbages and garlic and things like that and obviously vineyards um but then then they had pictures of them on their walls and then they you know they would go out and buy it and then eventually they would eat it but it's kind of just constant which is very italian actually if you go to italy now if you're having a meal with
似乎一直在吃东西。所以如果他们不是自己在花园里种植食物——他们确实在花园里种了很多东西，我们有很好的考古发掘成果向我们展示了他们种了什么，你知道的，他们有卷心菜、大蒜之类的一大堆东西，而且显然还有葡萄园——但除此之外，他们的墙上还画着这些食物的图片，然后你知道的，他们会出门去买，最后他们会把它们吃掉。这一切简直可以说是连绵不断，这其实非常意大利风。如果你现在去意大利，如果你和
an italian they'll they'll be talking about the next meal. So how many meals a day, Sophie? I think they were having three. I think the main meal, I think, in the day was lunch, if I'm not mistaken. I will always be grateful to you for taking me behind the scenes of the museum at Herculaneum and showing me the charred remains of all the figs and the grain. Amazing, amazing science.
一个意大利人一起吃饭，他们会一直在讨论下一顿吃什么。那么，索菲，他们一天吃几顿饭？我觉得他们一天吃三顿。如果我没记错的话，我觉得一天当中最主要的一餐是午餐。我永远会感激你带我参观了赫库兰尼姆博物馆的后台，并向我展示了所有无花果和谷物的碳化遗骸。太棒了，太神奇的科学了。
And the bread. Really amazing. Loaves of bread. But yeah, so all of that evidence helps us know exactly what they're eating. But yeah, I think the Herculaneum evidence is excellent for kind of saying across the board that these people were all enjoying a kind of really good diet. They were on fertile land next to a bountiful sea.
还有面包。真的太神奇了。一排排的面包。但是，是的，所有这些证据都帮助我们确切地了解他们在吃什么。不过，是的，我觉得赫库兰尼姆的证据极其出色，它能够证明这些地方的所有人都在普遍享受着一种非常优质的饮食。他们生活在富饶的土地上，紧邻着物产丰富的大海。
It was kind of perfect. Well, this brings us perfectly to John Hawke's question. He wants to know about, he's obviously a sewerage consultant or some sort of waste disposal professional. He wants to know about street cleansing. Was it dirty? Were people throwing their stuff out in the street? He questions whether there were sewers. There appeared to be little or no sewers, he says. Was it dirty? Were people throwing their stuff out in the street? How many were there?
这简直可以说是完美。好吧，这完美地引出了约翰·霍awk的问题。他想了解——他显然是一位污水处理顾问或某种废弃物处理专业人士。他想了解街道清洁情况。当时很脏吗？人们会把垃圾扔到街上吗？他对当时是否有下水道提出了疑问。他说，当时似乎几乎没有或根本没有下水道。当时很脏吗？人们会把垃圾扔到街上吗？到底有多少下水道？
He questions whether there were sewers. There appeared to be little or no sewers, he says. So, no, Pompeii does have a lack of sewers. I think there's one massive big one. But basically under the streets of Pompeii, there's none. They used, for their poo, they basically used sort sort of soakaways um they just had they just used the natural earth to kind of absorb um so yeah it's smelly uh so yes no there's one thing that i think a lot of people forget is is the smell of and i think it would have been pretty rancid at times um in terms of cleaning the streets there they are there are laws about making sure that your property is clean outside.
他对当时是否有下水道提出了疑问。他说，当时似乎几乎没有或根本没有下水道。所以，不，庞贝确实缺乏下水道。我想那里有一个巨大的主下水道。但基本上在庞贝的街道下面，是没有下水道的。对于排泄物，他们基本上使用的是某种渗坑……他们只是利用天然的泥土来进行吸收……所以，是的，那里气味很难闻。所以，是的——有一点我觉得很多人都忽视了，那就是气味，而且我认为有些时候那里的气味一定相当刺鼻。至于清理街道，当地确实有法律规定，确保你房产外面的区域保持清洁。
But that doesn't mean that it wasn't quite disgusting. And in fact, in the recent excavations, because they weren't just trying to get down to hard and fast archaeology in terms of roads and buildings, they were looking at all the sort of accumulations. They did find on a road a sort of a slew of shit, basically. And it kind of does show the state that some of these, you know, back streets might have been in. The main thoroughfares might have been really nice and clean and looked after because that's where the ediles of the town were kind of passing through. But the back streets may have been worse. But in terms of cleaning the streets, they had a sort streets, they used nature. And because Pompeii is on a slope, when it rains, they had water towers and things collecting water during drier seasons.
但这并不意味着当时的环境算不上相当恶劣。事实上，在最近的发掘中，因为他们不仅仅是想在道路和建筑物方面探究死板的考古学事实，而是研究了所有的堆积物，他们确实在一条路上发现了一大滩排泄物，基本上就是这样。这在某种程度上确实表明了其中一些小巷可能处于的状态。主干道可能非常漂亮、干净且维护得很好，因为那是城镇的市政官经常经过的地方。但小巷可能会更糟糕。不过在清理街道方面，他们有一种街道——他们利用大自然。因为庞贝地处斜坡，下雨时，他们有水塔之类在干燥季节收集水的设施。
But that would overflow and they would just let the water race down the street. And when it rains in Pompeii, if you're there now, the roads are like rivers. And then you suddenly realise why those little stepping stones are actually quite useful. So you can kind of avoid these torrents of water. So it kind of would have naturally cleaned itself, but people would have been involved. But yeah, it would have been a pretty smelly place. Yeah.
但水箱会溢出，他们就会任由水流顺着街道奔腾而下。如果你现在去庞贝，当那里下雨时，道路就像河流一样。然后你会突然意识到，那些小小的垫脚石其实相当有用，这样你就可以避开这些汹涌的水流。所以街道在一定程度上会进行自然清洁，不过人们也会参与其中。但无论如何，那曾经是一个气味相当难闻的地方。是的。
Of course, the people would have been very smelly, wouldn't they? Yes. Although they did enjoy their baths regularly. But the baths. They had a little oily smell to you yes wading around in other people's rooms yes okay this is this is the next question is from ian mckinney and it is something that we have touched on several times but let's just try and nail it down realistically is there likely to be any more completely new discoveries at pompeii or have we probably learned everything we're going to learn so i guess by that he means you know some spectacular building some amazing edifice but of course i mean that actually in a way what's most
当然，人们身上的气味一定也很难闻，对吧？是的。尽管他们确实经常去洗澡。不过澡堂里……身上会带着淡淡的油味，是吧？在别人的残羹冷炙里蹚来蹚去，是的。好吧，接下来的这个问题来自伊恩·麦金尼，这也是我们多次触及的一个话题，但让我们试着明确一下：在现实中，庞贝还可能出现完全重大的新发现吗？还是说我们可能已经了解了所有能了解的事物？所以，我猜他通过这个指的是某种壮观的建筑、某种惊人的宏伟建筑？但当然，我的意思是，事实上在某种程度上，最
fascinating is the kind of the tiny details graffiti or the exactly yeah unexpected unless they find unless they find the planning office I'd like that for my work. Sort of how houses developed and things like that, that would be really useful. But no, absolutely, the key is in the detail. And these new excavations have provided a lot of confirmation of what we already knew, which is reassuring. But they keep adding little details, new graffiti or signs that say somebody's running for political office or something like that so we we are building a picture but but things like the bar that really change how we know about their diet or what was being eaten in these fast food places which i mean i shouldn't call it fast food it actually makes me a little queasy calling that that yeah
令人着迷的恰恰是那些微小的细节，比如涂鸦或者……完全正确，是的。除非他们找到……除非他们找到规划局办公地点，否则很难再有意外之举。我倒挺希望为我的工作找到这个的。比如房屋是如何发展演变的之类的事情，那将非常有用。但毫无疑问，关键就在于细节。这些新的发掘工作为我们已经知道的事情提供了大量的确凿证据，这很令人欣慰。但他们不断增添着小细节，比如新的涂鸦，或者上面写着某人正在竞选公职之类的标语。所以我们正在拼凑出一幅完整的图画。但是像那家酒吧这样的发现，真的改变了我们对他们的饮食、或者这些快餐店里吃的是什么的认知——其实我不应该叫它快餐，叫这个名字反而让我觉得有点恶心
because we're labeling it as such i just yeah um but yeah no i think there's plenty to be found i mean one third of the city's still uncovered there's there's still a lot out there but i hope in a weird way i don't want to see it in my lifetime yeah if you but if you had a kind of dream discovery sophie if there's one thing you wanted to find a question that nags at you or a discovery what would it be um it would be the planning office it would be how people had you know uh if i mean if that's not the answer i was expecting oh sorry okay something more romantic i know but this is what you get when you work there too long and you're obsessed by walls you want to know did they get permission to add to their houses and change their property back you want to know if they got planning permission that's genuinely your the question that keeps you awake at night
因为我们是给它贴上了这样的标签，我只是……呃……不过，是的，我觉得还有很多东西等待被发掘。我的意思是，这座城市还有三分之一尚未被发掘，外面依然有很多宝藏。但在某种奇怪的层面上，我希望在我有生之年不要把它们全挖出来。是的。但是，索菲，如果你有一个梦想中的发现，如果你只有一件事想要找到，一个萦绕在你心头的问题，或者一个梦想中的发现，那会是什么？嗯，那会是规划局的办公室，会是人们如何拥有……呃——如果这不是你预期的答案的话。哦，抱歉，好吧，想要点更浪漫的发现，我懂。但当你在这儿工作太久、对墙壁着迷到一定程度时，你就会得到这种答案。你只想知道：他们给房屋加盖、改建房产时获得批准了吗？你想知道他们是否获得了规划建筑许可——这真的是那个让你夜不能寐的问题。
she should be writing the history of 1970s england uh yeah i haven't i haven't got a very romantic um notion on that sorry so not not the buried library well if it comes if if the if the planning office happens to be next to the library, then bingo. Everyone would be happy. I think we've covered a fair amount. Do you mind if I just crowbar in one thing that I carefully researched? Because I was asked the question, is there any evidence for Christians having been in Pompeii. And I think it's interesting because it shows how, in a way, how difficult it is to kind of make sense of the process of archaeology. Because it turns out that there was an inscription that was found in 1862 that apparently did, it has Christianos, so Christians, and it's conventionally translated as Bovio is listening to the Christians who are cruel haters is how it's conventionally translated. But the problem is that there
她应该去写20世纪70年代的英国史。呃，是的，我对这个没有抱持什么非常浪漫的想法，抱歉。所以，不是被埋藏的图书馆？嗯，如果——如果规划局恰好在图书馆旁边的话，那就太棒了，皆大欢喜。我想我们已经讨论了相当多的内容。你介不介意我硬塞进一个我精心做过研究的问题？因为有人问我这样一个问题：有没有任何证据表明基督教徒曾经在庞贝生活过？我觉得这很有趣，因为它在某种程度上展示了理解考古过程是多么困难。事实证明，1862年曾出土过一块铭文，上面显然有“Christianos”（即基督徒）这个词，它通常被翻译为：“博维奥正在倾听那些残忍仇恨基督徒的人的话”，这通常就是它的翻译。但问题在于，
were various transcriptions made of this inscription that was on a building that no longer exists. So the issue then becomes, you know, was it copied down correctly? And of course, because in the middle of the 19th century, people were looking for Christians in Pompeii. Was there a bit of wish fulfilment going on? I think the latest consensus probably it is authentic, but hard to know. And again, this will confirm Dominic's darkest suspicions. Yeah. Just when you think that you've got a really clinching piece of evidence, it kind of slips through your fingers.
当时人们对这块铭文做过各种转写，而这块铭文所在的建筑物如今已经不复存在了。所以问题就变成了：它当时被抄录准确了吗？当然，由于在19世纪中叶，人们满世界都在庞贝寻找基督徒的踪迹，当时是否存在某种一厢情愿的心理呢？我想最新的共识可能认为它是真实可靠的，但很难说。而且，这又一次印证了多米尼克最阴暗的猜疑。是的。每当你以为自己掌握了极其确凿的证据时，它就从你的指缝间溜走了。
Yeah, there's a crucifix in Herculaneum on the wall. There's the shape of a crucifix. People got extremely excited about this. And it ends up, it's probably just a fixture for a shelf. It's like ear fitting. You can't explain these things away. Yeah, but the same is true for Jews. I've been asked if there are lots of Jews in Pompeii.
是的，赫库兰尼姆的一面墙上有一个耶稣受难像。有一个耶稣受难像的形状。人们对此兴奋极了。结果发现，它可能只是一个架子的固定件。就像挂钩配件一样。你没法把这些事情解释得通。是的，犹太人的情况也是如此。曾有人问我庞贝有没有很多犹太人。
And, you know, we don't really have much evidence, but we know they're in Rome. But whether they're in Pompeii, hard to tell. But we do have that Indian goddess. But we do have that, yes. Let's cling to that. Well, Sophie, thanks so much. Pleasure.
而且，你知道，我们其实没有太多证据，但我们知道他们在罗马。至于他们在不在庞贝，很难说。不过我们确实发现了那个印度女神。但我们确实有那个，是的。让我们抓住这个不放吧。好吧，索菲，非常感谢。不客气。
Very, very exciting. After Stephen Fry, you are our first guest very very much he was a great warmer warmer pat thanks thank you sophie that was fascinating no my pleasure thank you very much okay we'll be uh we'll be back next week uh on my show and my special guest will be with me as well so we'll see you then goodbye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常、非常令人兴奋。继斯蒂芬·弗雷之后，你是我们的第一位嘉宾，非常非常感谢。他是个很好的暖场嘉宾。帕特，谢谢你。谢谢你，索菲，太精彩了。不客气，非常感谢。好的，我们将在——我们将在下周回到我的节目中，我的特别嘉宾也将和我一起出席，所以我们到时见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》，想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。